[Music]
okay just got done see an escape room
pretty good movie actually yeah we've
actually been looking forward to this
one because I've been seeing the
trailers for a couple of months now
premise on this one is that there's a
group of people kind of are kind of like
baited into this situation that they
think is kinda like a like a gameshow
type of deal where they did solve these
little riddles and escape these rooms
little riddles and puzzles yeah but it's
a lot more complicated than that bad
actually
I really can't really do a lot of spoil
can you spoil much about this because
there's a lot of stuff that you don't
expect but I didn't expect it to be this
good actually it was a pretty good yeah
it was like super fun and like some of
the some of the rooms cuz they shoot a
lot of the stuff in the trailer yeah
some of the rooms in there I was like
stressing yeah the movie is a constant
cliffhanger and I didn't realize it was
pg-13 you don't really notice it it
seems like y'all already movie yeah but
there isn't any gore in it no it's more
like a thriller
I guess comparisons to cube are going to
be inevitable but I thought it was a lot
different than cube um you know it's
yeah it's just vaguely similar premise
but it really doesn't play out exactly
the same also had little hints of saw
yeah maybe like the game that Michael
Douglas movie yeah like that but it's
kind of its own thing it's like I said
they did a really good job like kind of
building up and maintaining attention
like is acting as good as each new like
regulation comes out you figure out like
who all these people are you know why
they ended up here it's doing like that
the acting is good set set design all
looked really cool the concept was good
they set it up for a sequel you can see
that they're kind of going for a series
yeah well but yeah but if they come up
with another one I'll see it I liked it
it was a lot you know it's like I said
it stressed me out I was like if there's
a super tense and everything like that I
liked it I predict this in this movie
will do pretty well they're probably
well yeah I think okay guys
you
okay just got done seeing Mary Queen of
Scots which was a fury at peace taking
place in the 1500 it's about Mary Queen
of Scots yeah
the acting and it was very good I would
say that the costumes really good script
was kind of like something out of
Shakespeare the long movie felt long I
[Music]
like because I felt like well because it
was covering such a large so it moved
along it actually like a pretty good
clip I thought it was like you know they
had to skip ahead like several years you
know at varying points to get in all
that yeah all the important [ __ ] you
know what I mean but yeah I really
really liked the performances of the
Queen's and this and David Tennant as
scary you playing John Knox he's almost
unrecognizable like it should be here to
this big huge hat he's playing like this
kind of wrap arousing like yeah this
religious leader this is kind of a court
intrigue flick kind of like some of the
other ones usually you know period
pieces a European history or court
intrigue flicks but there's also a big
Catholic Protestant war going on in the
movie yeah what did you think of it um I
actually really liked it a lot it was
really like I like I said it really kind
of the pace of it felt pretty quick to
me the acting was really good it's just
I mean unlike the characters over
because it just goes to show that even
when you're the goddamn Queen of England
and or Scotland
you know you constantly have to worry
about these men like bitch-ass and
around behind your back trying to
undermine you at every turn because they
don't want to see anything yeah that's
like pretty much like it's sad because
it showed like even despite the power
that they had you know they were just
constant like plots against them and
like people you know even I mean brother
well these are cartels basically all
Memorial families but these are crime
cartels that's really what these are
these are not these are not good people
you don't get this kind of power by
being a good person yeah they were all
extremely rude sorry clear and really
the first part of the movie I was like
man this is a kind of a pussy-ass
version of what way these people really
were but then as it unfolded I'd say
yeah okay this is how they really are
because they starting to become murder
one another and that's who you're
dealing with
wait a minute people personally I kind
of thought the movie was long and
tedious it felt tedious kind of a
cumbersome script because they're
they're trying to be his kind of
historical or at least have the
appearance of historical accuracy I'm
not sure how accurate this movie is okay
so maybe it was but then reality doesn't
really make very good movies so to me it
kind of felt cumbersome and boring
really boring they the battle sequences
were lame there wasn't any comment it
wasn't any combat in them really it's
like they're setting up for a battle the
battle kind of happens off screen was
just kind of let down
I'm not I'm gonna crap on the movie is
really not to my tastes
other people would like it I think but I
didn't like it if you like historical to
us this is actually a really good I
generally tend to like that kind of
movie depending on what the subject
matter is and I've always been kind of
interested in European history so I
think from to my tastes it tried to be
too realistic other liked it better had
they gone the Excalibur rock like back
in the night early 80s late seventies
and done a fantasy version of this with
a bunch of sword fighting
alright guys house here later
okay I just got done seeing second act
with Jennifer Lopez and Lea trendy a
Remini was a fish out of water type
story about a woman who worked at a
supermarket as a manager I think and she
just couldn't get a she couldn't get a
promotion they can't bring that they
brought in like this guy that was a
toads that never worked there before he
just like had an MBA yeah exactly
so she couldn't get ahead in a corporate
world because no college degree she
didn't like that so a friend to hurt her
son it was like a computer whiz he makes
a badass online resume and a whole
background for that would pass FBI
scrutiny and it's like you know she goes
to Harvard she's climbed Mount
Kilimanjaro and she was in the Peace
Corps saving whales and just all kinds
of corporate [ __ ] and she gets
picked up by this big corporation that
makes like makeup any skin care
cosmetics and she knows about this stuff
you know she's worked at a store 15
years and she's like the manager but
she's got a [ __ ] her way through
this whole thing and it's kind of funny
that's that's the main start part of the
story but because it's kind of like a
secondary story element to it is that
she had given her daughter up for
adoption when she was a teenager it
turns out her and it turns out that this
grown daughter or first she gave up for
adoption works in this corporation and
it was it's not as coincidental yeah
yeah we don't want to split too much
about it but it's uh it was a good movie
what do you think uh yeah I actually
really really liked it I think the best
part of it for me was I really liked the
friendship between Jennifer Lopez
his name is Maya and Leah Remini yeah
they knock it out of the sewer just
really funny together I mean Leah Remini
she's awesome
yeah I never actually saw her on King of
Queens concidered I know that she's
mostly known for but she's awesome on
that anti-scientology and they're both
they're both still looking really good
240 j.lo still [ __ ] kicking it you
know she's looking really good so Selena
yeah good figure how old is she she's
gonna be 47
yeah she looks good but yeah like really
you know it's and it has like a lot of
heart to it too it's not me at all but I
think like my favorite part of it was
kind of like the interplay between those
two between like all their other groups
of friends of my own nose it was funny
like trying to like watching her
[ __ ] like the corporate world and
stuff I found that very amusing it's
kind of a general purpose movie for all
occasions that make a good date movie
it's a female-driven story I would
definitely say it's kind of like a chick
flick yeah but guys you know I was
laughing too you know yeah and like are
swearing children yeah but motivational
you don't feel good flick it's one of
those yeah it's good good movie for you
know daytime man Mayer yeah you are
[Music]